first they came for Aunt Jemima and I
said nothing because I don't like
pancakes and then they came for Uncle
Ben and I said nothing because I don't
like rice and now they're coming for
Goya and even if you don't like Puerto
Rican black beans you have got to speak
out because they are gonna come for you
whether you like it or not that is right
Robert oona new way or none way I'm not
quite sure how to pronounce it I will
call him mr. Goya the head of Goya foods
was invited to the White House he was
there to speak about his company and he
he committed a crime so atrocious so
outrageous that the popular culture will
not forgive him for it he said something
nice about the President of the United
States we're all truly blessed at the
same time to have a leader like
President Trump who was a builder and
that's what my grandfather did he came
to this country to build to grow to
prosper and so we have an incredible
builder and we pray we pray for our
leadership our president and we pray for
our country that we will continue to
prosper and and to grow it's basically
like listening into a Klan rally isn't
it it's just so so shocking and
outrageous now what's so funny
is that the left is making a big deal
out of this Koya endorsement of Trump
did it sound like he's endorsing Trump
I'm he's saying nice things but he says
Donald Trump is a builder just like my
grandfather was a builder regardless of
what you think about Donald Trump you
have to admit the guys at least a
builder right he's got his name on a lot
of buildings all around the country well
that was too far for the left even
though by the way this same man the same
head of Goya when he was called in to
work with the Obama administration said
nice things about Barack Obama it's just
respectful and how basic how obvious to
say we pray for our country we pray for
the president United States well they
called him on it and a lot of people
were just waiting for mr. Goya like
everybody else to fold under pressure
and say I'm sorry I didn't mean to be
nice to Trump well this guy's a little
bit different he turned to the mob and
he refused to bow I went to the White
House later
and introduced in Hispanic Heritage
Month President Obama and so you're
allowed to talk good or to praise one
president but you're not allowed when I
was called to be part of this Commission
to aid in economic and educational
prosperity and you make a positive
comment all of a sudden that's not
acceptable so you know I'm not
apologizing for saying and especially
recall by the president United States
you're gonna say no I'm sorry I'm busy
no thank you I didn't say that to the
Obamas and I didn't say that the
president Trump that's right my man I'm
not apologizing to the mob this is not
only the best wisest course of action
when the mob comes for you it is the
only course of action because the left
is gonna cancel you whether you try to
be nice to them or not it's in these
small little seemingly trivial stories
that the big issues play out black beans
matter I'm Michael knows this is the
Michael Nolt show
[Music]
welcome back to the show before we get
into the Democratic canceled culture and
the Democrats denying canceled culture
and why the Democrats did I cancel
culture and everything else first I want
to mention my favorite comment from the
show on Thursday this is from Dominic
which is that he can't wait for the
Kanye Trump collusion hearings
post-election me neither this is going
to be my favorite part I heard a lot
about Trump colluding with Putin turns
out there was no collusion at all but
can you imagine how much wilder it is
going to be to watch all of the the easy
responses to the collusion narrative
question for today please let me know in
the comments which company or product
should preemptively change its name to
protect itself from the woke mob the
Washington Redskins just announced about
15 minutes ago that they're gonna change
their name so that one's that one's
already out guys I was that was always
going to happen it was ever thus what's
the next one post whatever the new name
should be a best comment we will feature
tomorrow Democrats are calling for a
major boycott they're calling for a
boycott of Koya Chrissy Teigen who is
Chrissy Teigen I don't know I guess
she's a model or something I know I've
heard the name before but I'm sorry I
can't pay that much attention to this
dumb leftist culture Chrissy Teigen
tweets out quote f youuuuuu uck a shame
don't care how good the beans taste
though by by by by not eating Goya beans
anymore because the CEO said something
nice about the president and said that
he would pray for him Rep luis Gutierrez
former congressman posted in a now this
video since a left-wing media company he
posted out his shock and horror and and
how Goa beans now are responsible for
the oppression of Hispanic people this
is a video of my pantry filled with
Korea products I say to the owners of
Goya you came as conquistadores you
wiped out our indigenous population in
Puerto Rico you exploited the
Porto Ricans for centuries under your
colonialism and now you wish to bring
about more abdominal Trump who hates us
despised us and has treated the Puerto
Rican people with such cruelty
no more Goya boy Kaguya I will never buy
another product of yours again never
ever again could you imagine if the left
got this irate over an issue that
actually matters could you imagine if
they got this irate over school choice
or crime in Chicago oh man that would be
great we could use a little bit of that
passion as people are getting
slaughtered left and right in New York
and Chicago but they don't really care
about that they don't care about school
choice they don't care about giving
people opportunity they just want to
stand on their soap box on Goya beans
aoc did it do a Oh see the future of the
Democratic Party tweeted ed oh look it's
the sound of me googling how to make
your own adobo she's not eating Koya
anymore either the left is canceling
Goya it's crazy that they're focusing on
this tiny little nothing issue right now
really because for the left it's in
these small issues that all their rot
begins we'll get to that in one second
we'll get to them denying their own
canceling even though we just listened
to all of it but first I got to thank
our friends over at Rock Auto
you know it is very frustrating when it
can take hours just to give a simple
thing on your car fixed and trust me you
know how how I feel about this I don't
know anything about cars so I'm very
easy to scam when I go to an auto parts
store rockauto.com makes it so much
easier than walking into the store and
demanding quick answers to something
like hey is your car is that the LX or
the e X or the DX I don't know what I
don't know what type of X my car is then
usually the place won't have the part so
they go online anyway probably a rock
Auto and then they charge you twice as
much there are many types of course it's
impossible to keep all the parts stocked
you have access to rockauto.com though
at your desk or in your pocket
rockauto.com always has the lowest
prices it's it's based on the best deals
that you can get it's not always
changing it's not always gimmicky
rockauto.com
is a family business they've been
serving auto parts customers online
basically for as long as the Internet's
been around go to rockauto.com right now
see all the parts available for your
car or truck right Knowles Skinner wles
in the how did you hear about his box
and they will know that we sent you so
the left you see just calls don't buy
Goya Goya is terrible down with Goya I'm
never eating away again because they
said we'll pray for the president and
pray for our country then the left has
to deny that this is happening why do
they do this why why the focus why the
rage why is this rep Gutierrez like he's
giving the we shall fight on the beaches
speech from Winston Churchill about
black beans it's because in the 60s the
left told us the personal is the
political everything has to be
politicized by the left this has been a
theme that's come up for about a hundred
years now on the Left it comes you can
call it cultural hegemony you can call
it cultural Marxism you can call it the
long march through the institution's but
you can call it the personal is the
political you can call it whatever the
left has been saying this for a long
time that we they need to apply their
ideology to everything that's why they
care about political correctness that's
why they care about which pronouns you
use that's why they care about which
euphemism you use and you're allowed to
say people of color but not colored
people and you formerly could say
african-american but then it was black
again and then the these little minor
details are how they will control the
culture this actually comes back to an
Italian man named Antonio Gramsci who is
this Marxist founder the Italian
Communist Party and Gramsci along with
other thinkers applied the principles of
Marxism to cultural issues and what they
were hoping for something called
cultural hegemony which is that when you
infiltrate the culture itself the words
the the way in which we think the
products that we use the institutions
that we go to when you infiltrate that
it's much easier to achieve your
political goals then if you were to just
be a kind of old-school activist and run
a big campaign and try to get signatures
on your petition and try to win various
elections it's it's much subtler and the
left has had great success doing this so
they have to care about the black beans
I mean there's a you know we're joking a
little bit when you say black beans
matter that
now with a that's now what a protest
issue like black lives matter they're
using the exact same passion to talk
about Goya beans but it really is true
it's in these minor details and as they
do it they need to deny everything it's
funny we use the term cultural Marxism
if you google cultural Marxism right now
you'll see it says it's a conspiracy
theory an anti-semitic conspiracy theory
which is bizarre because the first
cultural Marxist and a valid cultural
Marxist a guy who says apply Marxism to
culture head of the Marxist party in
Italy was not Jewish at all he was an
Italian guy named Gramsci but they have
to deny it there have been so many
thinkers who have said we need to apply
these principles to the culture the
leader of black lives matter actually
all three leaders of black lives matter
right now are a valid self-described
trained Marxists but then they deny it
why because as many of these thinkers
say explicitly in their writings they
need it to be subtle you need to not be
aware that the culture around you is
changing so now their new line is that
cancel culture is not real this has got
to be news to all the people who have
been cancelled right we see these big
cultural touchstones of sorry you can't
be called this you can't be named this
Kevin Hart can host the Oscars because
you made a joke ten years ago so they
all get canceled they say you weren't
really canceled Charles blow from the
New York Times tweet seven one more
thing there is no such thing as canceled
culture there is free speech you can say
and do as you please others can choose
never to deal with you your company or
your product ever again the rich and
powerful are just upset that the masses
can now organize their dissent this is
what they're saying you're saying look
we're not cancelling anybody we're just
we're just telling you that if you have
an opinion that contradicts the
politically correct culture then we're
gonna organize a campaign to destroy
your life or if you said something ten
years ago we're an organized campaign to
destroy you look that's just the free
market of ideas man you don't have the
right to an audience a sec said the same
thing people are actually cancelled
don't get their thoughts published and
amplified in major outlets this has been
a public service announcement
so saying look whatever you can still if
you still exist if you maybe
get your voice heard and then you
haven't been canceled the left denies
that they cancel people even as they
cancel people because it's a little bit
of a subtle issue and they're trying to
confuse some terms so let's get very
specific on what canceling is we talked
about this a little bit last week are
all boycotts or ostracism x' cancel
culture no not necessarily we we at one
time had freedom of association at least
an american we still say that we do so
if you choose not to buy a product or
not to go to a certain place then you're
well within your rights to do that the
the difference is cancel culture is when
you boycott companies and ostracize
people for saying and doing things that
five minutes ago would have been
perfectly appropriate would have been
encouraged i mean the head of goya said
very similarly nice things about barack
obama but he wasn't canceled for that
and all he said here was i'm praying for
the president the united states he's a
builder and I'm proud of builders but
he's being cancelled for that
it's an explicitly leftist phenomenon
now most specifically canceled culture
involves going through some guy's past
and ten years ago he said or did
something that by the lights of today's
standards is no longer acceptable
and so it's an activist campaign to try
you to ruin his life
but I think the big difference here is
that there is a substantive difference
it's not just the form of it it's not
just all boycotts well it's it's the
substance what are you being boycotted
for conservatives don't want to talk
about this we want to just play umpire
we want to just have a set of rules and
in an ideological manifesto and say
we're gonna play play exactly by this
and hold everyone to the same standards
that's not what the left is doing and we
need to be able to make moral claims
pulling up the American flag and
honoring it in your backyard
is not the same act as desecrating the
american flag
they're both rituals that you do with
flags they're both expressions that you
make with a flag but they're not the
same thing one is good and one is bad
one should be encouraged one should be
discouraged
Nike shoes goes out and spits on America
they make the guy who who disrespected
the star-spangled banner their spokesman
they pull shoes that have the Betsy Ross
Revolutionary War flag they pulled them
because they say America so hopelessly
bigoted and racist from the very
beginning and that is perfectly fine
that company gets rewarded by the
popular culture even though I think the
particular expression that they're
making probably is unpopular with a lot
of people that's what we would call the
silent majority we'll get into that
later
so Nike gets applauded for that Gore
comes out and says I'm gonna pray for
our country and now we got a boycott
black beans that's not the same thing
those two things should not be treated
in the same way conservatives need to
grow a spine and realize that politics
is not just about form it's not just
about procedure
it's also about substance it's not just
about the right to say things it's about
what we're saying it's not just about
the right to boycott somebody its who
are you going to boycott there is so
much dishonesty going on in this debate
because it's all so unlike what aoc is
saying these are the people this is not
just a grassroots expression of feeling
a cry from the heart of the people this
is contrived BS from radical leftist
activists namely aoc namely the people
working at the new york times and we
need to be able to say this is wrong and
this is right we cannot trust though
that institution I mean we we say that
only the left can cancel people because
the left controls all of the
institutions sometimes some
conservatives go a little limp and they
go along with the left but the left
initiates the cancellation well we can't
trust the media anymore we can't even
trust them on free obviously forget
their reporting on coronavirus they've
been wrong from the very beginning but
now even when they talk about their own
personal experience with coronavirus we
saw this with NBC News a reporter
describing his personal experience even
that we can't trust we get to in one
second first of all I got to thank our
friends over at liquid IV you know I
love liquid IV and I learned this lesson
too late in life because for most of my
life all I drink is black coffee and
alcohol so I only drink things that
dehydrate me I would never have water I
was always taught you know it's very bad
for you to drink that water
so I was always very dehydrated liquid
IV is such a great way
to hydrate yourself you know believe it
or not dehydration occurs daily in three
out of four people pray occurred for me
most of my life with liquid ivu of the
fastest most efficient way to stay
hydrated each serving gives you as much
as as much hydration as two to three
bottles of water it just makes it very
simple a proper hydration is crucial for
your immune system and it can boost your
immunity with liquid IV you have the
fastest most efficient way to do it
plus it's packed with potassium vitamin
C all other sorts of good stuff that are
known to help your body defend against
infections it's really good if you're
athletic if you want to make sure you
protect your immunity and for me you
know if sometimes you go out and have a
couple adult beverages liquid IV is
available nationwide at Costco or Target
or you can get 25% off when you add a
liquid I be calm and use code Michael
mich a yell at checkout that is 25% off
anything you order when you use promo
code Michael at liquid IV com get the
new ginger flavor it's fabulous get
better adoration today liquid IV com
promo code Michael mi CH AE l NBC News
just when you think they can't lose any
more credibility just when you think
they're they're down to zero credibility
they somehow they go into the red they
go into the negative on the credibility
column an NBC News reporter these the
science contributor and biologist Joseph
fair went on TV to describe his personal
experience with coronavirus said it was
the worst he ever felt listen to his
harrowing tales of the virus doctor fair
let me start with you because I would
like you to share a little bit about
your recovery from Cova 19 what should
Americans take away from your experience
well first of all you know I did not
have any underlying conditions and you
know I'm not like a triathlete or
anything like that but I was generally
very healthy could run exercise probably
four or five times a week that being
said I did not expect whether if I got
covered 19 that I would get that ill
because I don't have any of those
underlying conditions I'm 42 years old
so you wouldn't think clinically that I
would be one of those people that would
get so very ill I can say that that's
seven to eight days prior to me
hospitalizing myself when I was doing
the seven
the self treatment that was the worst
I've ever felt I probably spent 23 out
of 24 hours in bed and then obviously I
developed the secondary pneumonia at the
end and so the the struggle in breathing
and everything don't so I was shocked at
how severe might illness got you know
without having those underlying
conditions that we've discussed so many
times I'm pretty shocked - I'm pretty
shocked to hear that 23 out of 24 hours
in bed that's that's not what seems to
be shown from the data what's what's
going on around the world certainly
around the country certainly for younger
men gosh that's really scary to me and
the the doctor here there are the the
scientific contributor the viral Auguste
has some advice encouragement you young
people you better take this virus
seriously so what I would take from that
is you know everyone that's younger
everyone that is going out without masks
now and being very cavalier with that
and ignoring this kind of ongoing
pandemic and you know we use the analogy
and the band played on with HIV and it's
response from the early days that's
really the analogy we should be using
with coronavirus right now to a much
greater extent and so those people that
are young and think they're invincible
or people that just don't think it's
going to affect them that greatly even
if they do get it I can say that my own
experience was the complete opposite
that it really you know I can't say that
I had a brush with death but I was
enough to put me in the ICU for four
days and in the hospital for six days
and say it's a brush with death but it's
pretty close huh
ICU for four days sleeping 23 out of 24
hours I mean I know that that the data
you know have contradicted all the scare
mongering from the mainstream media and
I know that all the experts and the
media the politicians have gotten
everything wrong but surely surely you
can't dispute this man's personal
harrowing experience it's scary right
it's crazy right
well the craziest part is he never had
coronavirus that guy tested negative for
corona virus and that guy tested
negative for the antibodies for corona
virus he never had it it's just
completely 100% fake
news that video that testimony
scandalized even me and I have no
respect for the media and I don't
believe a word that they say the
mainstream media the networks and the
New York Times and the legacy newspapers
I don't believe a word they say and even
I was shocked with how brazenly
dishonest that report was he didn't have
him he had something bad I guess it
sounds pretty bad but it wasn't the
virus and this is what we are basing our
public policy on this is what we're
basing the lockdown on this is how the
media work you because anybody listening
to that I don't care you the most
hardened skeptic of the lockdowns you
are as conservatives they get you here
that you say gosh I don't want that
virus but it's fake news and it's not
just fake Doosan the anecdotes it's fake
news on the data have you seen the
double standard in recent weeks maybe
not maybe I should remind you because
the news moves so fast you sometimes you
don't get to compare the headlines even
one day to the next so here's a piece
that came in Time magazine on July 11th
so not too long ago July 11th three
weeks after Trump's Tulsa rally Oklahoma
reports record high CO vid 19 numbers
it's pretty clear we know that
correlation is not causation you can't
attribute events that happen you know
around the same time they seem to be
related you can't attribute them to
cause and effect necessarily but it's
pretty clear from this headline Trump's
rally caused a spike in co vid but then
you think wait a second Trump had that
one rally in in Tulsa and you're saying
that's going to cause the all the super
spreading of Groening virus what about
the hundreds of thousands of people that
poured out into the streets to burn the
country down a few weeks ago what did
that that must surely that must have
been a super-duper effect on coronavirus
right well same magazine Time magazine
writes what 11 days before June 30th
nationwide protests haven't caused a
kovat 19 spike so far here's what we can
learn from that Trump holds a rally and
there's any coronavirus it's all his
fault
hundreds of thousands of people pour out
into the street but they're leftists
nope it's not them
nothing to see here folks pay no
attention wasn't just Time magazine NPR
sir search results come out party's not
protests are causing spikes in
coronavirus parties probably
conservatives who don't take the
seriously there they're crazy conspiracy
theorists or something wopo protests
probably didn't lead to coronavirus
spikes but it's hard to know for sure
look at the subtlety here they realize
how ridiculous it is to tell you that
the virus can discriminate based on
ideology but they do it anyway they just
say well look we're not sure but here's
here's the best science here's the best
LA Times experts see little evidence
that protests spread the corona virus in
the United States well they're the
experts and sure they've gotten
everything wrong but they've got lab
coats and stuff and degrees from fancy
places so they must be telling the truth
even the places that are telling the
truth aren't telling the whole truth is
there's a major focus on the exploding
number of cases that are being diagnosed
but there's an important measurement
that's being left out which we'll get to
in one second first though gotta think
our friends over at blink sale you know
blink sale if you are still using a word
processor to type up ugly invoices on
your computer and waste your time trying
to stay on top of that manually you are
burning money because time is money with
blink sale you can send beautiful custom
branded invoices and the estimates in
seconds you can stay on top of your
outstanding invoices and you can let
your customers and clients easily pay
your invoices online blink sale takes
care of it all so that you can spend
more time focusing on the work that
actually gets you paid and makes your
business a success as an added bonus
right now by the way blink sale is
giving away $10 to five hundred daily
wire listeners here's how you get it you
at a blink sale calm you start your
14-day free trial you create your first
invoice of $10 and you activate an
online payment option stripe or Pay Pal
then you send that invoice to daily wire
at blink sale calm you get paid your $10
the first 500 people to send an invoice
for $10 do daily wire blink sale calm
will get their invoice paid by blink
sale
unfortunately limit of one per person
otherwise I would have
done all of them before I did that read
today but I go check it out right now
stop wasting time invoicing try blink
sale for free bling sale calm / Knowles
bli nks al e calm / Knowles spend less
time dealing more time doing what you
love so all of the focus in the media
I'm sure you've heard it
the exploding number of cases there are
new masks orders even in Texas they're
training people to wear masks and lock
down the cases are exploding all thanks
to Trump rallies by the way not at all
thanks to the rioting of the last month
or so there there's an important measure
they're leaving out namely how many
people are dying there are a lot of
reasons why someone might be diagnosed
with kovat could be that there's
increased testing it could be that
people are more on edge so they're going
and getting tested it could be that more
people are getting it but the death rate
is significantly lower than the
superduper experts told as it was going
to be so it's not as deadly but how many
people are dying well let's turn not
just across the Atlantic let's turn to
maybe the one country that did not lock
down Sweden you remember Sweden oh the
civilised world said Sweden is going to
kill all of their population because
they're not shutting down the economy
and they're not forcing people to stay
indoors all the time Sweden took this
approach which I thought from the
beginning was the most reasonable
approach which is if you're very
vulnerable stay home and use precautions
and be fun Bok you're fine act
responsibly you'll be fine
Sweden's number of cases did shoot up
and they had some higher numbers of
deaths early on and now Sweden's
coronavirus death toll is approaching
zero this was the argument from the
beginning this is what people are
forgetting now my friends who were
telling me I've looked many liberal
friends were telling me we have to lock
down we have to wear the masks all the
time we can't go outside I said what
what is the purpose of that and they
don't know the purpose they don't
remember that we were told now it seems
like years ago 15 days to slow the
spread slow the spread not stop the
virus slow the spread flatten the curve
what does flatten the curve mean it
means exactly the same number of people
are gonna get it but it will spread it
out over time so
that the hospital system won't be
overwhelmed well we found out even in
New York where it was the worst because
Cuomo completely mishandled this we
found out they never even came close to
overwhelming the hospital system so we
succeeded in flattening the curve maybe
the curve would have been flattened
anyway even if we didn't lock down but
regardless because Sweden didn't lock
down they never overwhelmed that their
hospital system either but regardless
what else could the masks in the lock
downs achieve we're not gonna get hurt
immunity dr. fad she told us that maybe
we get a vaccine maybe we don't it'll
only work at best seventy to
seventy-five percent of the time the
thing is going to move through the
population so what is the argument there
isn't one
Sweden knew this so they took the early
hit now it's approaching zero here's the
headline from Business Insider Sweden's
coronavirus death toll is now
approaching zero but experts are warning
others not to hail it as a success okay
that's it I'm done with the experts then
that's amazing that headline is actually
almost honest which is that they're
saying yeah this is working and it's
great but the experts are really upset
because it proved them all wrong and
it's destroying their credibility and
it's not allowing them to control
everybody now unfortunately on this even
as these skeptics the Conservatives have
been proved right it's time and time
again even as the hysterical people the
alarmists in the media in politics in
activism even as they're proven wrong as
the experts the public health experts
they've been proven wrong every step of
the way there is still a lot of pressure
on conservatives to cave and I'm sorry
to say president Trump exhibited a
little bit of this the other day he put
on the mask he wore the mask I think it
was a big mistake now I think he
redeemed himself a little bit later
we'll get into that as well but we'll
get into the politics of the mask these
little tiny things where the rock begins
first though I've got to thank you for
subscribing to the Michael Dahl show I
if you go to Apple podcasts you can
subscribe there leave a five star review
we really appreciate it and you can
subscribe to the Michael Noel's show on
YouTube be sure to check out my
interview we just had when I was hosting
men's radio show with Matty Kern
my friend at national review and my
debate with Jessica Tarlov my friend at
FoxNews over voter excitement with Joe
Biden we got a lot of stuff over there
so go check it out if you are not
already a daily wire remember you should
consider getting a reader's pass today
Lee Weyer com it's 99 cents a month for
your first month that's my gift to you
you also get access to our mobile app
articles ad free and access to exclusive
editorials go to daily wire calm then
it'll increase to the huge experience
super duper expensive price of 3 bucks a
month still pretty good cheaper than cup
of coffee but you can sign up for just a
buck and go buy Ben's book with all of
this craziness people ripping down the
statues journalism has no credibility
right now in the mainstream and Ben
coincidentally talks about that in his
new book how to destroy America in three
easy steps you can pre-order your signed
copy at daily wire calm slash Ben get
your copy today we'll be right back
President Trump put on the mask I
suggested it that this would be a bad
idea I begged him not to do it but he
did it anyway and I think it was a bad
look it's not the end of the world it's
a small thing it seems right to put on
the mask but what the message that it
sends is really bad it sends a message
first of all to the rest of the world
which is projecting weakness when the
leader of the free world muzzles his
face covers himself up it shows weakness
now you might say well masks are
effective I don't think they're
particularly effective not the cloth
ones at least but regardless I'm not
talking about the efficacy of masks
medically that's a separate issue it's
the message it's what it's what it's
showing and it shows weakness but it
also shows weakness to the left because
what it says to the left is you were
right I the masks are effective I
shouldn't have not worn a mask I should
have worn a mask weeks ago and that's
exactly what the left is saying right
now do you think Trump got credit for
wearing the mask no of course not Karen
Tumulty at Washington Post said that now
this is evidence that all conservatives
should wear the mask Jake Tapper said
quote someday someone will do a study on
how many lives might have been saved if
this happened in February or March you
know that's absurd of course but they're
right it's it's an absurd statement that
live we lost all these lives because
Trump didn't wear a mask it's an absurd
statement to say conservatives should
now wear the masks but they're right in
that Trump gave them the premise it was
I don't know who's advising him I don't
know who's advising him but it was a
horrible look and whoever's advising him
to do this should be fired or they
should at least be sidelined and not
listen to any more it was a bad idea
first of all why is it absurd what these
mainstream media people are saying
because back in March I know he's got
memory hold and we all forgot but all
the experts told us not to wear masks
even the exalted doctor foul Qi who was
sitting opposite his interviewer neither
of them wearing masks he said it would
be stupid for people to walk around at
the height of coronavirus by the way at
the moment that this thing was exploding
he said it would be stupid to wear a
mask right now in the United States
people should not be walking around with
masks you're sure of it because people
are listening really not closely to this
right now people should not be worried
there's no reason to be walking around
with a mask so now after the virus has
already spread that's when we need to
wear masks but when it was exploding in
the country and we were trying to
flatten the curve that's when we didn't
need to wear masks that doesn't make any
sense we were told that masks are not
effective then we're told they're
effective now it seems they're not
effective again but they're still
telling us to wear them there's only
loss to be had if Trump wears the mask
what's to be gained he hasn't worn a
mask yet he hasn't gotten the virus
seems healthy to me the messaging has
been good it's rallied the base which is
what he's going to need to do in
November there's no gain here there's no
win president Trump's campaign manager
Brad purse Cal tweeted out a picture of
Trump wearing the mask I can't believe
it I can't believe he would promote this
this image that is going to be
dispiriting to the base and it's going
to be encouraging to Trump's most
vociferous critics because they're gonna
take a victory lap and say we were right
based on nothing needlessly but he
tweeted it out he said hashtag America
first what does that get us
what does that get the campaign what
does that get the public health
he should be tweeting out videos of foul
she and March telling people not to wear
masks that's what we should be tweeting
it very frustrating whoever advised him
to do this is probably the reason why
the rest of the messaging in the imaging
right now and the campaigning is not
going as well as it could be now that's
sad the good news is Trump has been very
strong in some other areas he's been
very strong on insisting that schools
must reopen in the fall again though
mixed messaging is it full steam ahead
let's reopen or is it we got to take
this very seriously we got a muzzle
ourselves and wear masks all the time
even if the science is out on whether
they're effective or not and we can't go
certain places which is it you got to
pick a lane if you stand in the middle
of the road you're getting hit by a
truck so at least on the school issue is
full steam ahead we're gonna punish
schools if they don't reopen you've got
to do it no surprise the left
is furious including the former
Democratic vice-presidential nominee the
man who was just one or almost one
heartbeat away from becoming the second
woman president senator Tim Kaine I am
really really distressed with the way
the administration is handling this the
question is not whether schools will
reopen they will reopen in the fall the
question is will they reopen online or
in person or in some combination
give me a break dude you are obviously
gaslighting on this nobody believes that
going online is reopening reopening is
reopening doing zoom classes is not
reopening that's closing and all the
issues that go along with keeping the
schools closed like what parents are
gonna do with their kids how they're
gonna arrange their work schedules what
quality of the education is going to be
that the kids are receiving those all
remain so he gaslight the beginning
denies the problem and then of course he
accuses Trump of promoting quack
medicine who do parents of school-aged
kids trust to make that decision do they
trust local principals superintendents
in school or school boards or do they
trust Donald Trump and Betsy DeVos
Donald Trump has preached quack medicine
Donald Trump denied this was a health
problem Donald Trump wouldn't wear a
mask until the sixth month of this
crisis Donald Trump makes his own
supporters sign
liability waivers before they attend
campaign rallies boom with the parents
of school-aged kids trust their own
principals superintendents school board
members are Donald Trump it's not a hard
question
so the accusation is the Trump reaches
quack medicine did you catch that verb
though the verb gives away the whole
game
he says preach medicine you don't preach
medicine you prescribe medicine you
study medicine you analyze medicine you
cultivate and develop medicine but you
don't preach it preaching is a word that
is associated with religion not hardened
materialists empirical medical science
but the way that the left is treating
this virus the way that the left
is treating science generally is in a
religious way that is divorced from data
that can tell you that one protest is
good for the virus one protest is bad
for the virus that can tell you one day
don't wear the masks the next day wear
the masks and they pretend that nothing
has changed they Gaslight you onions a
little issues
it's that religious fervor and let me
ask you to Tim Caine's point who do you
trust on the virus do you trust the
people who've gotten it wrong from the
beginning
the experts and and the media war do you
trust Trump who has a much better record
on it than any of these other people so
so I thought this was good on the
schools Trump took it a step further too
he's now threatening the funding the
government funding of the university
system not just for coronavirus or
reopening or whatever even though we've
seen these silly stories last week about
Harvard still charging students 50 grand
a year to do zoom classes but he's
threatening them generally because they
are not fulfilling their educational
mission he tweets out too many
universities and school systems are
about radical left indoctrination not
education therefore I am telling the
Treasury Department to re-examine their
tax-exempt status and/or funding which
will be taken away if this propaganda or
act against public policy continues our
children must be educated not
indoctrinated now again there's a little
bit of there's a little bit of a
difficulty here because the word
education and the word indoctrination
basically mean the same thing to
indoctrinate comes from the word Doge ra
in Latin which just means to teach so
one has a good connotation one has a bad
connotation I think we've got to stop
talking about the form only the
procedure only and talk about the
substance the universities and the K
through 12 school systems still have the
form and the procedure of the same old
educational systems we've known the
whole time the kids show up they go to
classes they have teachers they have
certain they choose a major in college
even with zoom they still have a similar
structure in the way that their
education will be will progress what has
changed is not the form but the
substance and conservatives don't want
to talk about the substance because we
want to pretend to be hands-off because
we want to pretend you can't legislate
morality because we want to pretend that
everything's neutral it
neutral nothing is neutral anymore
everything is political it may be it
always was but the left is told us
everything is political right down to
Goya beans okay so you're not gonna get
out of this you're not gonna be able to
say I'm not telling you what to think
just how to think because part of
education is teaching you what to think
what to know what about history you know
historical revision is one of the
clearest ways that the education system
has been perverted historical revision
and historical erasure are at the heart
in many ways of the present madness of
toppling all the statues and defacing
George Washington we'll take this story
just came out May I think on Friday no
Hagia Sophia one of the most beautiful
oldest cathedrals in the world which was
then taken by Muslim invaders and turned
into a mosque and then since 1934 has
been a museum it's in Istanbul which
used to be Constantinople is now
reverting back to a mosque so after
almost a hundred years the Muslim
government in Turkey is taking this
World Heritage Site and turning it back
from a museum into a mosque now all the
coverage is saying it's being converted
back it's going back to what it was and
it feeds into this idea we need to go
back and and give people reparations for
historical wrongs we need to go back and
give the land back to the Indians Nathan
we've got to give Oklahoma back to the
Indians we got to give Mount Rushmore
back to the Indians why stop there with
the Hagia Sophia it's so clear why would
you just stop in in 1453 which is when
the Muslim Ottomans stole the Hagia
Sophia one of the most beautiful
cathedrals why not go back I don't know
for the 916 years before that when that
building was built to be a Christian
Cathedral and stood that way for almost
a millennium
why don't we revert back to that why
don't we revert Istanbul back to
Constantinople because all of these
claims the anti-colonialism the
anti-racism meld they only go in one
direction they only seem to be used to
exploit the West and no other
civilization is ever held to those
standards they're simply a
tax and we say they're minor little
things oh this debate over words this
debate over one little sight one little
piece of territory who cares when you
grant those little premises
who cares with the mask when you grant
those little premises you grant the left
its entire cultural hegemony and it has
real effects
I'll show you one very practical effect
we're in an election year we're coming
up on an election in November we're all
worried about voter fraud especially
with the mail-in ballots because because
if we grant the premise that the virus
is SuperDuper deadly and we're all gonna
die if we don't put the masks on and we
lock we have to stay like to them we
can't go back to school
well one consequence of that premise
which is BS but one consequence of it is
people can't be expected to go vote
that'll be very busy so they we have to
have nationwide mail-in ballots and that
we are told is not going to result in
any voter fraud that's what the left
tells us even though we've been
prosecuting cases of obvious voter fraud
just in the past couple months well in
Atlanta the Tim's family Ron
Tim's goes to his mailbox and he takes
out his voter registration mail-in voter
registration he got one was a card for
Cody Tim's who's Cody's Cody his wife
Cody his brother Cody's one of those
names you know kind of cuts either way
it's Cody his son no Cody is his dead
cat who died 12 years ago here is Ron's
wife Carol describing the cat a great
cat indoor/outdoor loved his family
loved the neighborhood he was 18 and a
half when he passed away we have a voter
registration application for Cody Tim's
how this happened I mean it's not
reality he's kept here he is and he's
been dead for a long time there's a huge
push but if they're trying to register
cats
I'm not quite sure who else they're
trying to register I don't know if
they're registering dogs I think if it
could be dogs what's next
it's the slippery slope Democrats have
always relied on dead voters to win
elections we can trace this back at
least to John F Kennedy in 1960
sometimes they rely on dead people to be
their presidential nominees but they've
always relied on dead voters but now
they're taking a step further more
brazen they're relying on dead cats if
we grant the premises of the masks and
the lockdowns and the schools and all
these little things it's not a
coincidence it's not just by accident
that we will end up granting the
premises that will give the left a major
political and cultural advantage even as
other countries that don't have
presidential elections in three months
are reopening and everything is going
just fine over there wonder why I guess
Sweden doesn't have a very highly
contested presidential election this
year even in seemingly ridiculous news
stories you see the rod Sports
Illustrated Swimsuit Issue do you get
that when I was a kid you know
occasionally if there was one lying
around maybe I would have taken a look
but not in a while have I ordered Sports
Illustrated I don't read Sports
Illustrated I don't think many people do
but they've made history this year
because for the first time they will
have a dude on the cover of their
swimsuit issue no it is a dude who
thinks that he's a woman or pretends to
be a woman who dresses like a woman but
it's a dude talk about a gender parity
you know talk about rising up over the
oppressive yoke of the established class
finally men who have been excluded from
the Sports Illustrated Swimsuit Issue
for so long finally we get to overcome
that oppression from the women from the
matriarchy and wear bikinis on the cover
of the of the issue this guy valentina
sampaio
is is going to appear on this cup on the
face it seems like a stupid story
nobody cares no one even reads Sports
Illustrated but this a little story
carries a lot of significance the reason
that the left is pushing this transit
which affects what how many people are
genuinely confused about their sex well
more and more each day but as a medical
matter very few a vanishingly small
percentage of people but the left has
pushed this for years the bathrooms the
transgenderism in Hollywood Halle Berry
is now not allowed to play a woman who
thinks that she's a man because women
who think that their men can only be
played by men I guess that's another win
for the oppressed men over the
matriarchy the reason they're pushing
this is because at the heart of that is
a cherished leftist premise which is
that there's no difference between men
and women the sexes are not
complementary they don't go together
they're indistinguishable they're
identical men can be women women can be
men we're all just sort of the same
we're all just these floating atoms we
have no natural constraints by our
biology no natural social constraints by
say our family or our local communities
or our voluntary associations we are all
just free-floating
atoms this is why sometimes you'll see
when there are big debates between the
most arch libertarian the most arch
communist they both have the same
premises which is that people are just
individuals that can do whatever they
want basically and then one group says
they should all be separated all the
time and one group says they shall be
brought together all the time when
they're all separated it's much easier
to bring them together which is why the
advance of hyper SuperDuper
individualism tends to lead to a growth
of the state now is all of that
contained within the Sports Illustrated
Swimsuit Issue is all of our all of
these premises contained within a dude
wearing a bikini and the cover of a
magazine
this radical liberation that we can
overcome it yes it is but we don't
notice it that's cultural hegemony
that's political correctness whatever
you want to call it that's how insidious
it is it's why we have to pay very close
attention to the small things on the
great television show that the crown the
Queen's private secretary Tommy
Lascelles has this great line which is
he's talking about why it matters that
we pay attention to our rituals to our
traditions he's talking about
in the wake of the abdication of Edward
the eighth and the line is it's in the
small things that the rot starts do the
wrong thing once it's easier to do it
again do the individualistic thing once
it's easy to do it again that's what
we're seeing here that's why this
relentless push where the FA masks do
they do that just do it just to use the
effing pronoun call him/her just do it
it's nothing it doesn't matter it's not
important let men go change in the
little girl's room just do it it's not
important well if it's not important why
do you seem so intent left wingers on
forcing us to do it if it doesn't matter
if it's just a small thing because it's
not just a small thing even small things
are not small things that is where the
rot begins and that is why even as a
matter of grave national importance
black B in this matter that's our show
I'm Michael owns the Michael Nolt show
I'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies executive producer Jeremy
Boren supervising producers Mathis
Glover and Robert Stirling technical
producer
Austin Stephens assistant director pavel
madoski
editor and associate producer danny
D'Amico audio mixer robin fenders hair
and makeup nikka geneva production
assistant ryan love the michael knowles
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20
you know the Matt Walsh oh it's not just
another show about about politics I
think there are enough of those already
out there we talk about culture because
culture drives politics and it drives
everything else so my main focus is our
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about I
hope you'll give it a listen
you